[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro d' europe hebdo je suis
ravi de vous accueillir ici au parlement
européen à strasbourg
pour cette nouvelle demi heure
d'actualité européenne à la une de cette
édition cet accord sur le brésil trouvé
entre les négociateurs britanniques et
européens
une étape décisive dans ces négociations
qui n'en finissait plus de buter sur un
point celui de la frontière irlandaise
nous en discuterons tout au long de
cette émission avec nos invités nous
partirons aussi au portugal qui affiche
depuis quelques mois de très bons
indicateurs économiques
une embellie qui embarrasse bruxelles
car depuis bientôt trois ans le
gouvernement de gauche d'antonio costa
applique une politique anti austérité
mais nous le verrons dans notre
reportage ses résultats reste à pondérer
car certains chiffres masquent une
réalité plus contrastée mais d'abord
revenons sur le break citer cet accord
technique trouvé entre les britanniques
et les européens un texte obtenue au
prix d'âpres négociations
écoutez sa réaction alors enfin il ya un
accord mais on sait on doit maintenant
voici ça va passer d'un au parlement
britannique est aussi un conseil ici et
je sais que chez moi c'est c'est
vraiment difficile cette passion du tout
les équipes européennes était prêt sous
la houlette de michel barnier ont
travaillé très dur très bien en veillant
à l'intérêt de l'union européenne et les
britanniques il fallait éviter le piège
que les britanniques ne sortent mais
guère des avantages du marché intérieur
ça c'était inacceptable évidemment donc
c'était évidemment compliqué la question
irlandaise
était pas le moindre épineux des
problèmes et donc je pense qu'il ya
encore des étapes à franchir
je me réjouis qui est une avancée quand
même dans la négociation car mais tout
n'est pas bouclé et pour en discuter
j'ai le plaisir d'accueillir sur ce
plateau jean arthuis bonjour bonjour
vous êtes français membres de l'udps et
y est vous appartenait au groupe des
démocrates et libéraux dans ce parlement
européen à vos côtés aujourd'hui charles
tannock bonjour bonjour les gars vous
êtes britannique est membre du parti
conservateur alors la première question
pour vous jean arthuis le référendum sur
le brésil c'était il ya plus de deux ans
on arrive enfin à un accord technique
c'est un soulagement j'imagine pour les
européens oui c'est un soulagement
maintenant c'est un accord provisoire
dans la tente d'un accord plus plus
structurelle mais ça reste un
soulagement on va prendre du temps pour
trouver des termes plus précis et mais
peut-être que c'est un accord qui durera
il s'agit d'étendre ce qu'on avait
imaginé pour régler le problème de la
frontière entre l'irlande du nord et
l'irlande d'étendre cette union
douanière
une mesure très très exceptionnel de
l'étendre à l'ensemble du royaume uni sa
note donc c'est un pas significatif dans
ces négociations dont on attendait enfin
dont on était plus sûr finalement quelle
qu'elles aboutissent
je rappelle quand même que la commission
européenne en début de semaine présenter
encore son plan d'action en cas de nos
deals et bien c'est un accord comme un
démon collègues pas provisoire parce
qu'il n'y a pas beaucoup de temps pour
les négociations maintenant
il nous reste que quatre mois en fait à
mon avis c'est le meilleur possible dans
les conditions politiques et les limites
des déclarations faites par le
gouvernement britannique
alors c'est un modèle qui se rapproche
un peu au modèle de jazz et dans les
îles anglo normandes
alors justement on le sait le principal
point d'achoppement dans ces
négociations
c'est la question de la frontière
irlandaise revenons un peu en arrière en
décembre 2017 lorsque theresa may
s'engagent à éviter le retour d'une
frontière entre l'irlande du nord
territoire britannique et la république
d'irlande membres de l'union européenne
un engagement pris pour préserver les
accords de 1998 qui avaient mis fin à 30
ans de guerre civile en irlande
les européens avaient alors proposé que
l'irlande du nord reste dans l'union
douanière européenne une solution
écartée par les britanniques qui
préférait voir l'ensemble du royaume uni
demeurer dans l'union douanière de
manière temporaire
une option rejetée à son tour par les
européens quel compromis 'achat' à
'neutre'
on était la prise le problème ça sera
dans la question du deal pays que c'est
la partie forte ce ton qui donne son
appui au gouvernement britannique pour
rester au pouvoir
à mon avis ils ont dit hier que comme il
y aura encore des contrôles sur des
règlements européens des petites
contrôle que à mon avis ils ne veulent
pas appuyer l'accord et s'ils votent en
contre ça sera vraiment grands risques
programmes aux britanniques
sylla et s'ils ne sont plus d'accord
avec qu'elle reste au pouvoir que le
gouvernement minoritaire est voir ça
sent encore un autre problème plus grand
pour madame mais alors c'est vraiment à
ces critiques les prochaines semaines en
sera miens bien renseigné parce qu'il
faut lire le document mais il n'ya aucun
doute qu'à mon avis de rester comme cela
membres de l'union européen c'est
beaucoup plus c'est beaucoup supérieur
et mieux que avoir l'accord de ses
gendres à s'il ya la possibilité d'une
deuxième possibilité c'est possible en
deuxième référendum
ça c'est la sphère des britanniques bien
sûr l affaire des députés européens
la solution trouvée est celle qui est
proposée là est une solution pragmatique
pas d'un thé ou une pragmatique mais le
diable de sera dans les détails parce
que la grande bretagne va rester dans le
royaume uni va rester dans l'union
douanière marché intérieur donc ça veut
dire que les droits de douane seront
perçus en grande bretagne mais reversé
au budget de l'union européenne
ça veut dire qu'on va également demandé
à la grande bretagne de ne pas faire
marche arrière s'agissant de normes
sociales de normes environnementales qui
sont aujourd'hui en vigueur en europe
mais c'est beaucoup beaucoup plus
beaucoup pire que rester comprend
membres de l'union parce que sinon on
aura on l'a on n'aura plus aucun
méthodes de législation alors on va
recevoir les loin européens mais sans
aucune possibilité de les influencer au
de l'échangé et ça pour moi c'est encore
pire et ça c'est intéressant que les
lots critiqué les propre et un beau coup
de sang contre cet accord parce que
c'est un compromis qui ne plaît pas à
tout le monde parce que c'est un
compromis a lancé cinéscénie nice l
indépendance totale avec notre
possibilité d'avoir notre politique de
commerce extérieur parce qu'on reste
dans le union douanière et on n'est pas
aussi ici pour l'enfance et les doigts
et faire les droits qu'on avec notre
partenaire européen long à mon avis
alors à des problèmes dont le parlement
national de la choisille a choisi le
moindre mal mais
tout ceci ne peut être que provisoire
peut-être est-ce le prélude au retour de
la grande bretagne dans les eaux à
rennes moi je serais pour ça bien sûr
mais c'est il ya la petite possibilité
dans le cas que cette si cet accord
n'est pas à voter dans la chambre d'écho
main qu'il y aura un une deuxième
référendum et là la bataille sera d' une
référendum avec l'option de rester
complaints membres merci beaucoup à tous
les deux d'avoir été nos invités
aujourd'hui je vous propose maintenant
de revenir en images sur plus de deux
ans de négociations sur le brésil du
référendum du 23 juin 2016 à l'accord
technique qui vient d'être conclue
d'âpres discussions entre le royaume uni
et les vingt-sept dont nous vous
rappelons les étapes clés
23 janvier 2013 david cameron premier
ministre promet aux anglais de les
consulter sur le maintien de la
grande-bretagne dans l'union ce jour là
il ne mesure pas encore le séisme qu'il
va déclencher
s'il remporte les élections législatives
sur cette promesse et malgré sa campagne
contre le break site
le wind emporte avec 51,89 % est des
suffrages des missionnaires david
cameron est remplacé par el la
conservatrice theresa may une re
sceptiques convaincus et partisane d'un
bric si dur lorsqu'elle annonce vouloir
sortir du marché unique 29 mars 2010 est
le premier ministre britannique écrit au
président du conseil européen et
déclenché la procédure prévue par
l'article 50 du traité de lisbonne des
taxes s'ouvre alors une période de
négociation sans machine arrière
possible
quel sera le montant de l'enveloppé
financière à régler par la grande
bretagne pour honorer ses engagements
européens déjà contractés quid du sort
des ressortissants européens déjà vivant
sur le sol britannique
quelle relation et accords commerciaux
et douaniers subsisteront avec l'union
déjà complexe l'équation d'un encore un
peu plus ce compliqué theresa may
fragilisé s'appuie désormais sur le
parti unioniste irlandais le dlp pour
remporter des législatives anticipées
un allié encombrant qui veut rester
coûte que coûte arrimé à la grande
bretagne au risque de rétablir une
frontière physique entre l'irlande du
nord territoire britannique et l'irlande
du sud membres de l'union européenne
malmenée par sa coalition entre les
tenants d'un bric site durée des
partisans d'une sortie négociée
theresa may se fait régulièrement
chahuté à la chambre des communes
jusqu'à l'éclatement de son gouvernement
et de départ en juillet 2
18 de son tonitruant ministre des
affaires étrangères boris johnson
septembre 2018 theresa may pense avoir
trouvé la solution à l'équation
irlandaise pierre d'achoppement de la
signature d'un accord avant d'être
sèchement contredite au sommet de
salzbourg par les 27 chefs d'états
européens alors que la perspective d'un
no deal se profilait l'accord technique
survenu mardi 12 novembre apparaît comme
une possibilité fragile de sortie de
crise
et pour continuer à parler de cet accord
sur le breakbeat m'a rejoint sur ce
plateau ana gomes bonjour vous êtes
portugaise membres du parti socialiste
est dans ce parlement européen vous
faites partie du groupe des socialistes
et démocrates à vos côtés aujourd'hui
philippe lambertz bonjour je vous êtes
belge membre du parti écolo en belgique
et coprésident du groupe des verts dans
ce parlement européen et pour compléter
ce plateau j'ai le plaisir de recevoir
godelieve quiz tout de revol bonjour oui
bonjour vous êtes allemande membres de
la cd ou et du parti populaire européen
oui philippe lambert ce on a beaucoup
parlé ces derniers mois du risque d'un
odile sur certains secteurs de
l'économie notamment cet accord
technique c'est donc plutôt rassurants
selon vous mais pour l'instant il n'y a
pas d'accord rien de garanti évidemment
que c'est d'accord à ce la rampe à la
chambre des communes qui landes est très
divisé et le risque que la chambre des
communes rejette l'accord est loin
d'être négligeable autrement dit le
risque d'une ode il demeure et donc
j'appelle en tout cas chacune et chacun
à décider en son âme et conscience et
surtout en ayant l'intérêt général à
l'esprit parce qu'un une sortie du
royaume uni sans accord serait
extrêmement dommageable bien sûr pour le
royaume uni mais aussi pour tous les
états riverains du royaume uni à
commencer par l'irlande mais bien sûr
tous les états qui ferait de la mer du
nord
il reste encore beaucoup d'étapes à
franchir selon vous oui je les mêmes
opinions que les collègues et que le
collègue des verts je crois que c'est
surtout aux britanniques eux-mêmes
maintenant de faire les par l'union
européenne a fait ce qu'elle pouvait on
a fait des propositions valables
ici je j'ai l'impression qu'au sein du
parlement européen
tout le monde partage plus ou moins la
même opinion avec des tailles
différentes
mais c'est passé important eh ben c'est
à londres qu'il faut qu'on travaille
et là moi je vois pas que c'est fait
aussi parce que les animosités
personnelles c'est pas objectif tout ça
et ce n'est pas neutre en ce sens qu'on
ne regarde pas ce que les traités est
bien ou pas est-ce que l'accord est
valable mais on regardait ce qu'on aime
theresa may est-ce qu'il faut autre
chose
est ce qu'on peut faire la révolution
incarne
à la chambre sauf quand même et vous
venez comme vous êtes optimiste sur
l'issue je suis du même avis il faut
voir aussi que nous au parlement
européen on doit aussi ratifié cet
accord s'il est en fait accepté par la
chambre des communes et donc on a toutes
ces questions mais je pense qu'au
parlement européen
devra le faire si on si l'accord a fait
respecter nos lignes rouges et les
droits des citoyens nos citoyens et les
citoyens britanniques chez nous sont d
une question primordiale
moi en tant que socialiste portugaise
j'aimerais que les forces notamment du
lait bas demandent un deuxième
référendum
et vous pensez que c'est possible une
possibilité je pense que c'est possible
tout est possible c'est beaucoup plus
possible aujourd'hui ça semble plus
possible au jury qu'il semblait il ya
une année c'est quelque chose que l'on
souhaitait aussi philippe lambertz un
deuxième référendum
moi ce que je souhaite c'est que le
royaume uni reste au sein de l'union
européenne et donc si les forces
démocratiques au royaume-uni parviennent
à faire accoucher une pareille décision
c'est à dire soit que ne pas sortir soit
sur sortir formellement mais en période
de transition décidé finalement de
revenir je m'en réjouirai maintenant il
nous appartient pas à décider comment le
royaume uni doit doit gérer la chose je
pense que une intervention de des
responsables politiques des vingt-sept
dans le débat interne au royaume uni
sera en fait contre-productif
très bien alors je vous propose pour la
deuxième partie de ce débat de changer
de sujet de prendre la direction du
portugal pays qui fait figure
d'exception dans l'union européenne avec
ses mesures anti austérité après trois
ans de coupes budgétaires imposées par
le précédent gouvernement
les socialistes au pouvoir depuis 2000
15 soutenu par une union des gauches
applique une politique de relance par la
demande des mesures qu'ils prennent
bruxelles à contre-pied et cela semble
marcher avec de bons résultats
économiques mais attention certains
indicateurs sont à analyser avec mesures
car il cache une réalité plus sombre
voyez ce reportage de sandra cerqueira
[Musique]
des ruelles pittoresques qui bouge et se
transforme lisbonne s'offre un coup de
jeune
le centre historique est envahie par les
grues et les immeubles en ruine font
place à des hôtels il s'en ouvre une
dizaine de nouveaux chaque année ça
c'est un immeuble qui a été récupéré par
nous entre 2011 et 2013
quand on lâche t il était complètement
délabré cet investisseur français a
racheté ce bâtiment une bouchée de pain
500 euros le mètre carré
aujourd'hui les 12 chambres de cet hôtel
sont réservées de mars à novembre
il dit même avoir du mal à recruter du
personnel j'ai l'impression que portugal
du point de vue touristique a profité de
la crise donc ce qui a fait qu'à partir
de ce moment là pas mal d'emplois se
sont créés dans l'hôtellerie jusqu'à
jusqu'à maintenant et c'est pas fini et
c'est pas fini
là par exemple en ce moment on parle
d'un nouvel aéroport un nouvel aéroport
qui devrait voir le jour dans deux ans
parce que l'aéroport actuel ne peut pas
accueillir tout le monde
[Musique]
après plusieurs années de crise le boom
du tourisme a contribué à l'embellie
économique du pays la croissance ne
faiblit pas 2,3 pour cent cette année et
le taux de chômage est passé de 17 à -2
9% d'une renaissance que le pays
attendait depuis longtemps
[Musique]
à 30 kilomètres de lisbonne cette
entreprise de pièces détachées notamment
pour l'industrie automobile voit ses
exportations sans cesse augmenté c'est
ce modèle qui va être exporté en
roumanie
le dirigeant ne s'attendait pas à une
telle reprise qu'il a même dû recruter
une dizaine de salariés
ils sont aujourd'hui une quarantaine en
cdi à travailler à temps plein nous
n'avions plus aucun investissement au
portugal plus aucun client nationale
nous avions perdu tous nos contrats et
avons évité de peu les licenciements
aujourd'hui l'industrie nationale a
retrouvé une certaine stabilité
notre entreprise se porte mieux qu'avant
la crise championnat crise selon lui
rien n'aurait été possible sans les
mesures prises par le gouvernement de
gauche portugais et l'ue en 2015 alors
que l'europe entière se serre la
ceinture
depuis trois ans le portugal mène une
politique de relance loin de l'austérité
imposée par bruxelles
avec une augmentation du salaire minimum
à près de 600 euros en échange d'une
baisse de cotisations pour les
employeurs il est clair que cette
politique de relance du gouvernement a
contribué à stimuler l'économie
ça a été une aide réelle l'augmentation
du pouvoir d'achat et donc de la
consommation dans le pays ont permis de
getafe 1 1 mais si le portugal réalise
de belles performances sur le plan
économique et prévoit de ramener son
déficit à 0,4 pour cent du pib
une ombre au tableau perdure celle de la
dette publique
autre problème la baisse du taux de
chômage qui pour cet économiste cache
une réalité plus sombre
le marché du travail reste précaire
bon nombre d'emplois créés depuis trois
ans dans le secteur du tourisme
notamment sont des contrats court qu'un
peu qualifiés et mal rémunérés sur le
marché du travail portugais hong kong
redonne 2% de cdd c'est l'un des plus
hauts niveaux d'europe et malgré la
baisse du chômage il est toujours aussi
difficile pour les jeunes diplômés de
trouver un emploi
photo justin vaisse
cet infirmier a enchaîné les contrats
courts pendant plusieurs années avant
d'être titularisé son souhait que le
retour aux 35 heures attribuées aux
fonctionnaires soient généralisés il a
le sentiment que le redressement
économique ne profite pas encore à tous
le gouvernement a délaissé les
infirmiers cela fait un an que nous
attendons la revalorisation de notre
statut et de nos salaires le
gouvernement s'était engagé à le faire
quand la situation économique sera
meilleur c'est le cas aujourd'hui et
après plusieurs jours de grève rien ne
change mobilisés depuis des semaines
ils réclament plus de moyens pour
l'hôpital public progrès tant que le
gouvernement mise davantage sur
l'investissement privé l'hôpital je
travaille en périphérie de lisbonne se
trouve dans un état de vétusté tels que
nous n'avons plus de conditions de
travail satisfaisantes
des travaux ont commencé il ya trois ans
et aujourd'hui ils sont à l'arrêt faute
d'investissements publics d'un reprise
économique est là mais dans le secteur
public nous n'en tirons pas vraiment les
bénéfices dans son entourage certains de
ses collègues infirmiers sont sur le
point de quitter le pays car même s'il a
diminué avec la reprise l'exode des
jeunes diplômés portugais continue
[Musique]
alors première question pour vous un à
gomes vous appartenez au même parti que
le premier ministre portugais antonio
costa le portugal 1 qui a confirmé sa
réputation de bon élève de la zone euro
en présentant son projet de budget à la
commission européenne le pays vise un
déficit à 0 1% c'est quoi le secret
alors le secret c'est de se libérer de
cette recette qui était complètement
erronée de l'austérité je ne dis pas la
rigueur fiscale et la différence qui a
été fait avec ce gouvernement socialiste
avec le soutien parlementaire à la
gauche c'était cet engagement de
retourner des revenus aux familles comme
ça de pousser à la consommation
intérieure donc aussi aider aux
exportations de se développer et en même
temps avec la rigueur de la gestion des
comptes publics qui nous a permis cette
trajectoire donc de deux équilibre
fiscal de manière beaucoup plus clair
que jamais mais le côté plus sombre
on l'a vu dans ce reportage c'est le
manque d'investissements publics
philippe lambert bien sûr bien sûr il
n'ya pas il n'y a pas de miracle le bon
c'est clair que les finances publiques
du portugal avait besoin d'être
restaurée je pense en effet que les
recettes qui ont été adoptées au
portugal sont
je dire plus conforme à la science
économique autrement dit on voudrait
nous faire croire que les politiques
visant à comprimer les salaires a
compris mais sans fin des dépenses
publiques pour permettre en fait aux aux
détenteurs de capitaux de s'enrichir
sous prétexte que les détenteurs de
capitaux sont ceux qui font fonctionner
l'économie mais en fait ces recettes là
ne sont pas fondées dans la réalité
elles sont fondées sur une fausse
science
la théorie économique néo classique qui
n'a aucun fondement réel
je pense qu'il est bien que le
gouvernement portugais s'en soit il a
nié ceci dit si vous voulez à une
société à haut niveau de vie vous devez
faire la course à la valeur ajoutée en
tête et je pense que nous européens
devons être extrêmement attentif à cela
parce que il ne faut pas croire que le
reste du monde va se contenter d'être
notre usine d'assemblage je vais dire la
chine monte dans la chaîne de valeur
indique est extraordinaire si nous ne
sommes pas capables de faire la course
en tête dans les activités à très forte
valeur ajoutée et bien donc nous aurons
un problème et je pense que c'est un
processus
on ne peut pas demander au portugal ou à
n'importe quel état européen de
transformer son économie en un
claquement de doigt ce n'est pas
possible mais en tout cas c'est
clairement l'accent doit doit se trouver
la priorité alors il ya aussi un autre
indicateur sur lequel il faut avoir une
double lecture 1 c'est la baisse du
chômage celle de livres christ ou de
revel je crois que la première chose à
faire c'est vraiment d'essayer d'avoir
autant un chômage qui est aussi bas que
possible même si les contrats ne sont
pas toujours magnifique je crois qu'il
vaut mieux travailler si on n'est pas
capable de vivre de son travail
on peut ajouter de l'aide de l'état mais
d'abord intégrer autant que possible
surtout les jeunes dans le monde du
travail et ça d'une façon positive parce
qu on a une toute autre opinion de soi
même si on est capable de réaliser
quelque chose absolument première
priorité
on a un sens bon évidemment en tant
qu'allemand tracé d où la politique
d'austérité
on connaît mais je crois que les
économies
en europe toujours très différentes en
allemagne on est plus ou moins d'accord
on a été plus ou moins d'accord avec la
politique d'austérité maintenant il ya
un certain changement de mentalité qui
se fait mais ça vaut pour l'allemagne
pourquoi pas en fait d'un autre côté il
faudrait maintenant des investissements
publics et on va s'y mettre
ce n'est peut-être pas valable pour
toutes les économies quand je voudrais
justement qu'on revienne sur le cas
italien le gouvernement a annoncé qu'il
maintenait son projet de budget malgré
le rejet par la commission européenne un
budget jugé hors des clous par le
commissaire aux affaires économiques
contrairement aux années passées
la commission n'a malheureusement pas pu
considérer le projet de budget italien
conforme à la recommandation du conseil
adoptée unanimement en juillet dernier
je pense non je ne pense pas je suis
certain que la commission loin d'être un
frein pour l'italie agisse comme un des
moteurs tels investissements en italie
et c'est un allié pour la croissance de
ce pays alors en 2016 dans le portugal
risquaient aussi une amende mais c'est
une procédure qui a été abandonnée au
bout d'un mec parce que justement le
trajet fait par le gouvernement
socialiste a permis à la commission de
libérer le portugal de ce procédure de
déficit excessif et ça a eu des
retombées énormes parce que ça fait
baisser les
ce qu'on paye des intérêts par notre
dette publique qui est toujours très
élevé mais quand même elle se réduit
clairement et ça a diminué donc le poids
des dépenses par rapport à la dette
publique parce qu'aussi les agences de
rating
car elles mais elles ont aussi remis le
portugal au même niveau qu'elle était
avant la crise et ça été positif
mais je dois dire que je suis d'accord
avec mes collègues l'investissement
c'est une question public c'est une
question essentielle directrice et ça ne
dépend pas seulement du portugal
ça dépend beaucoup de l'europe si on a
une politique qui notamment au niveau de
l'allemagne
aussi aide à la convergence au sein de
la monnaie unique de l'hérault et donc
qui encourage l'investissement public
et puis on a un grand problème et il
faut dire une des conséquences de cette
austérité de la traite pas seulement au
portugal mais les pays qui ont souffert
l'osteria sic on a vendu très bon marché
des secteurs critiques de notre de nos
enfants structure de notre économie
et pas seulement pour le portugais pour
l'union européenne il faut savoir que
par exemple la le aujourd'hui c'est le
parti communiste chinois à travers ces
compagnies l'état qui contrôle le
produite la production et la
distribution de l'énergie électrique au
portugal c'est quand même grave pour
l'union européenne
vous êtes d'accord c'est une une
responsabilité très lourde comporte ce
qu'ils sont qui ont défendu l'austérité
au niveau européen
vous êtes d'accord avec d'autres
collègues oui en 2018
mais au moment où on affaire où on a
privatisé tout ça la situation était une
situation différente et on n'a pas pu
voir ont tellement loin dans l'avenir
mais si on regarde maintenant par
exemple l'italie les plans d'une italie
de privatiser le porte gel avec l'argent
chinois d'inviter des investisseurs
chinois maintenant en 2018 alors là je
crois qu au vu de la de l'économie
globale qu'il faut faire très attention
maintenant il ya toujours moyen de
retourner ce qu'on a fait dans le passé
en grèce par exemple on a voulu
privatiser le port d'athènes moi je
trouve que en principe un port privé est
une bonne chose
en principe et je me rappelle que dans
le temps dans la grande crise grecque on
a essayé de trouver des investisseurs en
allemagne et les allemands ont dit non
c'est trop risqué alors ce sont les
chinois qui sont venus est bien là
c'était une faute
pourquoi ne pas faire ça
au niveau européen pourquoi ne pas
prendre le risque et avoir assez de
confiance
oui dans notre système européen dans ce
que nous disons beaucoup austérité ou
austérité une forme de dogmatisme du
marché qui est à l'oeuvre en europe
depuis 30 ans évidemment qui a été
accélérée à l'occasion de la crise cette
idée que si vous privatiser ça sera
mieux géré si vous privatiser ce sera
moins cher si vous préviens tease et ce
serait plus efficace que constate-t-on
on a privatisé au royaume uni les
chemins de fer et une bonne partie des
services publics on l'a fait un peu
partout en europe que constatons c'est
que ça coûte plus cher à l'état
c'est moins bien géré tout parce que
tout simplement la logique de ce qu'on
appelle bien improprement les
investisseurs jeudi les détenteurs de
capitaux est l'extraction de la rentrer
ce n'est pas créer de la valeur pour la
société sait extraire de la société une
rente et vous payez donc cette rente
comme usagers que vous ne payez pas
autrefois lorsque vous payez par vos
impôts les services publics et donc ce
dogmatisme de marché il faut en sortir
et il est inscrit dans nos règles
budgétaires puisque en fait on pénalise
l'investissement public parce qu'on
demain en tenez vous bien à ce que les
pouvoirs publics lorsqu'ils investissent
comptabilise la tegra lite et de
l'investissement
l'année où l'investissement est fait
c'est comme si tout comme en entreprise
vous créez une nouvelle aciérie et on
vous demande en fait de ne pas vous
endetter pour faire une aciérie qui
m'appelait durer 30 40 ou 50 ans ça n'a
évidemment pas de sens comment se fait
il qu'on écrit dans les règles
budgétaires des choses qui n'ont pas de
sens pour en fait donné l'impression
qu'il est impossible que l'état
investisse merci beaucoup c'est ainsi
que se termine notre débat aujourd'hui
merci à tous les trois d'y avoir
participé merci à vous de nous avoir
suivis et vous pouvez retrouver cette
émission en replay sur nos différents
sites lcpan public sénat et rtbf.be très
belle semaine à tous et à très bientôt
[Musique]